let's talk about how to choose your
proteins wisely
now the problem with protein is that
in nature protein never comes as a
complete protein it comes with
fat and there's such a thing called the
insulin index
which looks at the protein effect
of insulin so in other words the leaner
the protein
the more the spike in insulin if you
want to get into ketosis very very
deeply
you don't want to do the lean protein
you want to do more
fatty or protein now if we look at the
ketogenic diet as far as a pie chart
five percent should be carbs and i
failed to also add another five percent
for salad and vegetables because i don't
count those into the
equation so roughly 10 carbs but half of
that should be
vegetable and 20
protein and then we have 70
fat so we're just going to focus on the
fat the protein right now
so if we look at 70 fat
to 20 protein we're looking at the
percentage of
calories and you can see wow that's a
lot of fat
to protein right it's actually three and
a half times more fat
than protein but if we take a look at
the actual weight in grams
simply because there's more uh condensed
energy
in fat than protein then we're dealing
with a different ratio
we're dealing with 1.56 to one ratios
so we're talking about weight okay
because when people say wow you're
eating this high fat diet you're eating
70 of your calories fat it's really kind
of like a
a little more than a one to one ratio so
when you really look at it from a weight
point of view
it doesn't look that unreasonable okay
so the more that we can align ourselves
with this ratio right here
the more truly keto it is now
if we increase this even more
we have more fat to protein then we're
going to generate
more ketones and this is what they do
for epileptic children
the diet is very very high in fat
because they're trying to
generate enough ketones from the fat to
really make it work
and when you have more fat to protein
it's
really good on your digestive system
it's a lot better
than doing leaner proteins and of course
that depends on what type of fat you're
talking about
but what happens too is when you
increase more fat you increase
more stimulation of bile from your liver
to actually digest the fat
people who are on a low fat diet end up
with
a deficiency of bile and they're more at
risk for
getting gall stones which is interesting
all right let's take a look at this
chart right here it's very very
interesting so we have fat
and protein we're just looking at kind
of the ratios here an egg is the one to
one ratio
so if you're eating egg maybe you add a
little more fat to that
um you could do it several ways you
could add a little butter or whatever
hamburger two to one that's a pretty
good ratio
twice as much fat as protein so
hamburger is a really good thing to do
for keto i consume
a lot of hamburger steak look at this
one to two
wow most steak that you eat is just not
fatty enough and people tend to cut off
the fat they don't eat the fat
so if you're gonna do a steak maybe make
sure you add more fat to
that meal all right chicken actually
it's lower in fat
higher in protein so there's twice as
much protein as fat
but i'm not sure about this one because
here's the point if you're eating this
with the skin with where there's some
fat underneath it
this might even out to a 1.1 uh ratio
so always eat the skin on on the chicken
all right bacon one to one now you would
think it'd be a lot higher in fat
it is but you're frying off all the fat
so
if you're doing bacon you want to
actually add some more fat to the meal
okay look at this a pecan seven to one
pecan is very very fatty of course we're
not talking about saturated fats we're
talking about
omega-6 fatty acid and there's a little
bit of carb
okay there's a tiny bit of carb but
pecans are a really good nut
to consume i consume pecans probably on
a daily basis
this is a good ratio all right now let's
talk about the peanut it's
two to one it's good ratio but many
times if i eat a meal
i will have some peanut butter with
celery just to get a little bit more fat
in the diet all right cod liver
now i'm not talking about cod liver oil
talk about
cod liver it's right here check this out
icelandic cod liver maybe you've never
heard about it before
there's many different brands most of
them
are wild caught okay so that's the one
you want to get
i don't know if they get it all from the
same place but this
is quite good look at the ratio
five times as much fat to protein this
is definitely ketogenic food
and the oil in it actually is all
from the cod liver okay so i'm not
saying you're gonna
drink the whole thing uh you could and
maybe you should
you can actually put it in the
refrigerator and have a little bit each
day but yesterday i consumed an
entire can it was a little too much fat
in one sitting
but if you did a half of this you'd be
great but yesterday i was not hungry
for the entire day i think i just had
one meal and normally i'll have two but
this is extremely
satisfying summer sausage now
what is summer sausage it's a type of
sausage
here's an example that you normally
don't need to refrigerate it unless you
open it up and then you put in the
refrigerator this one
it says to refrigerate okay that's cool
but this is
something that i consume on a regular
basis as well of course this one is
organic
uncured summer sausage the problem is
trying
to find summer sausage without dextrose
which is synthetic sugar
and without nitrates now this does have
celery juice
and i did a video on this topic it's
true that
celery juice does have nitrates and so
therefore
people say well it's the same as the
nitrates you would get
from other sources right but there's
really
no studies that i could find that said
that
consuming celery juice with the nitrates
has any harmful effects so it may create
some harmful effects
but if you know of a study put it down
below
but i'm still alive i've been consuming
this for a long time
so this has organic beef sea salt
all right and then it has organic honey
now i know what you're going to say
you said not to have honey this is a
very very small amount
i'm okay with it it's like one gram per
serving
so it's pretty low and then we have
organic spices
cultured celery juice powder
lactic acid starter culture
but this is like a two to one ratio so
it's it's actually perfect
if i'm in a hurry i can just chop this
off i might add some cheese to it i
might just have it by itself
and i'm good to go and also
lucy our little granddaughter who's two
right now
loves this and it's it's pretty healthy
and i know someone is going to want to
know
where do i get this you're going to have
to look it up i have no affiliation with
these
companies um but i will put a link down
below of of the names of these so you
can do the research
on them okay then we get to the
macadamia nut
look at this 11.5 fat
to a one protein ratio
this is quite killer nut
in a good way all right sardines now
check this out
here's an example of some sardines you
would think
it'd be fattier but look at it has twice
as much protein
as fat but it comes in oil
so a lot of that oil is going to shift
this is probably going to be like a one
to one ratio so this is i consume
sardines it's totally fine
you need to do it but look at this
salmon
1.5 to 1. so apparently salmon
fits this closest it's the ideal keto
food
i love salmon i love fatty fish i
consume salmon
on a regular basis salmon also has
selenium to counter any potential
mercury that's in that
fish but of course you want to do wild
caught all right in summary if you want
to get into a little deeper ketosis
focus more on the proteins that are
higher in
fat thanks for watching hey before you
go real quick
i have a course entitled how to
bulletproof
your immune system it's a free course i
want you to take it
and here's why here's you
here is your environment
everyone is focused on this over here
avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today